comment est-ce que ça roule aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous allez bien alors
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de deux
nouveaux produits ce sont deux nouvelles
tablettes alors avant de rentrer dans le
dur du sujet de vous montrer les
tablettes gpon accessoires qui vont avec
vous allez voir c'est intéressant la
toute première c'est la mecque pad 11
may pas drôle ici c'est écrit noir sur
blanc la meille pas de 11 qui va avec
son smart magnétique qui borde un petit
clavier qui l'avait qui est super bien
très pratique à c'est très cool vous
avez d'un autre côté mais pas de pros
mais pas de pros écrit ici et le mail
paltrow qui va également avec son smart
magnétique qui bordent pour mettre pas
de pros et avec ça vous avez les aime
pencil ce sont des stylets qui
permettront de venir utiliser cette
tablette à la main si vous souhaitez
écrire dessiner prend des notes et
compagnie on va regarder aujourd'hui que
vous propose ses tablettes qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire il ya une notion qui
est très important de chez huawei c'est
la notion d'écosystème je sais pas si
vous êtes coutumier si vous connaissez
les produits de huawei mais ils sont
interconnectés il ya un vrai écosystème
c'est une des vraies force de la marque
si vous avez par exemple un p 40 trop
vous pouvez venir faire tout communiquer
très facilement entre les différents
produits qu'ils soient sûrs du nepad que
ce soit avec un ordinateur doit louer un
pc vous avez des écrans derrière des
moniteurs qu'on peut venir l'utiliser
aussi bref il ya tout et très
interconnectés on va donc regarder
aujourd'hui ce que proposent les mails
pad comment ils sont qu'est-ce qu'il
vous permettent de faire et si on a deux
produits ça c'est le mail pad 11 mai aps
annonce qui sera forcément plus petit
que le mec pas de pros la différence de
taille et quand même vraiment importante
alors on va commence tout de suite par
le mic fad 11 premières choisi si c'est
la diagonale d'écran 10,95 pouces écrans
120 hertz résolution 2,5 qu'à 16 10e
c'est un écran est certifié lutter
contre la lumière bleue il est une
certification tüv rheinland on a une
petite caméra qui est planqué là qui
servira pour me reconnaître votre visage
ou pour déverrouiller très rapidement je
la trouve très réactive il faut dire ici
qu'on tourne sur un dragon en 1865 alors
ici pas de 5 g vous avez vous connecter
en wifi côté graphique c'est une adreno
650 on a soit 64 128 giga de stockage et
on a six giga de ram qu'on peut venir
monter jusqu'à un terrain vous avez une
très grosse batterie de 7250 millan
paire eur et sur le map pack 11 la
recharge 22 25 watts ici l'autonomie qui
donnait par ouais c'est à peu près 12
heures de lecture de vidéos en streaming
tout ça tourne sur harmony os alors
harmonie os je sais pas si vous
connaissez c'est l'expérience logiciel
de huawei pour continuer sur matériel
vous avez quatre haut parleurs
2 3 4 c'est la stéréo travail avec arman
cardon également pas moins de quatre
micros pour avoir collé sur une période
où on fait beaucoup de télétravail et on
communique grâce aux objets
technologiques et un côté pratique puis
vous avez une caméra à l'avant de 8
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0 et vous
avez à l'arrière regardez ici là une
caméra qui planquaient juste ici c'est
une caméra de 3 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
1.8 premier film échéant quatre cas si
vous le souhaitez après une tablette
s'est pas trop fait pour venir faire des
photos et des vidéos c'est plus un petit
complément et vous avez sa grande soeur
c'est le mail pas trop le mail pad prova
être forcément un peu plus grand vous
avez un ratio châssis écran qui va être
de 90 % ici une dalle qui fait 12 6
pouces débord 2,5 2,6 mm on sache où
passe un petit peu côté très technique
on est sur un mélange d'aluminium et de
magnésium qui apporte de la solidité et
la légèreté on fait ici 600 g c'est un
écran oled
2560 par 1600 pixels dci p3 écran super
amoled et vous avez delta e qui a fait
rieur à 0,8 un contraste de 1 million
pour un écran hd r10 plus et si vous
n'avez pas quatre haut-parleurs vous
avez huit haut parleurs qui sont
répartis tout autour lui haut-parleurs
également calibrée est conçu avec harman
kardon à l'intérieur ici on n'est pas
chez qualcomm on est inquiet rinne 9
1000e pas de 5g vous avez uniquement une
version wifi classique mais moi je reste
convaincu que sur les tablettes mieux
vaut acheter une version wifi vous
faites du partage de connexion avec
votre smartphone plutôt que de mettre de
la 4g ou de la 5g sur sa tablette lui
giga de ram 256 gia de stockage
extensible grâce à une carte micro sd si
vous faisiez de recharge et de la
superbe charge en 40 watts vous avez une
batterie de 2050 milliampères heures on
a à peu près 10 heures d'autonomie et
vous pouvez recharger également sans fil
27 watts et vous avez également de la
recharge à verser 10 watts sommeil pas
de preuve d'un petit peu plus à
l'arrière au niveau des caméras une 12
mégapixels c'est votre grand temps 8
mégapixels c'est votre ultra grand-angle
et vous avez une caméra 3d tof time of
light qui me sens viendra à venir
mesurer des meubles si vous souhaitez
par exemple est toujours une caméra
cette fille qui est planqué à l'avant
pour venir déverrouiller votre ipad avec
ses tablettes vous avez les smart
magnétique qui bordent de taille
différente la taille pour le pro la
taille pour le 11 le principe est
exactement le même un clavier vous êtes
soit 55 degrés soit 65 degrés
aujourd'hui c'est l'angle d'inclinaison
vous venez on se prend il se pose très
facilement il se connecte directement
avec ça vous avez les aime pensi dès
lors les aime pencil ils sont aussi
intéressants parce que ce sont les
nouvelles générations c'est la 2
génération vous avez une différence par
rapport à la première opération qui est
juste là vous avez évidemment de la
recharge sans fil vous le posez
directement sur votre tablette de cette
manière là et il vient surchargé très
rapidement et c'est extrêmement pratique
vous avez également un revêtement qui
amélioré cap il 96 points de pression et
une latence de 2 millisecondes une
fonction double tap lorsque vous venez à
écrire le double tap et ici il faut il
changer par exemple la mine de vol stylo
lorsque vous faites du dessin de la
prise de notes très très facilement et
surtout les mines ici c'est une bille
avant c'était du plastique donc ça sera
beaucoup mieux pour venir dessiner
prendre des notes travailler et écrire
tout en sachant que si vous avez déjà un
stylet de huawei que vous souhaitez pas
réinvestir et bien votre ancien style et
reste malgré tout compatible et ce
nouveau style est par contre est
également compatible sur les anciennes
tablettes de huawei et avec votre stylet
en 45 minutes de charge vous êtes parti
pour 10 heures d'autonomie des tablettes
qui sont bien évidemment en wifi 6 je
connais la question qui vous brûle les
lèvres c'est la question des usages
qu'est ce que je vais me refaire cette
tablette alors vous en douterez déjà une
tablette vient d'utiliser tout seul sans
rien sans stylet c'est une tablette vous
la prenez pour du contenu multimédia ça
ira parfaitement bien pour venir
regarder des photos des séries des films
pour venir jouer à des jeux on peut
venir le faire faire quelques petites
photos alors on peut faire des photos
mais pour autant ce n'est pas sur une
tablette que je vais venir faire des
photos mais si vous voulez vous pouvez
le faire donc l' usage tablette telle
qu'on la la il est très simple très
basique que ce soit sur l'un ou sur
l'autre produit dans les deux cas vous
allez avoir smart magnétique qui bandent
alors le smart magnétique qui borde la
première intéressés de venir protéger
votre tablette ça c'est bien le deuxième
intérêt c'est que vous avez un petit
clavier en dessous des pouvoirs venir
utiliser lorsque vous allez me retaper
donc ça c'est plutôt très pratique le
côté un petit peu plus négatifs que je
vais me retrouver ici avec ce petit
smart magnétique keyboard est bien c'est
que j'aurais aimé avoir un petit côté
trackpad voyez pour venir naviguer ça
c'est un peu le petit bémol parce que
même si ce n'est pas un ordinateur on
peut vouloir venir faire des usages de
productivité bureautique est la maison
rassurez vous ils sont malins chihuahua
ils ont pensé à tout pourrait venir
liées une souris bluetooth qui fait de
vous transformer ce combo là en petit
ordinateur de productivité à la maison
pas faire des miracles mais on peut
d'ailleurs vous allez voir qu'on peut
faire beaucoup plus de choses avec et
grâce au stylet que vous avez avec il
vient se poser et qui se rechargent
extrêmement facilement eh bien on peut
venir griffonné prendre des notes
dessiner le mec patron on sera plus
destinés à des étudiants pour de la
prise de notes pour de la collaboration
dans le cadre de leurs études également
dans l'univers professionnel avec des
commerciaux qui veut faire un reporting
et qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de puissance mais il y
en a quand même sa dragonne 865 croyez
moi qui en a ici le mec pad pro
permettra d'aller un peu plus loin en
terme de créativité cite par exemple
vous voulez faire de la vidéo un peu de
montage vidéo là on va pouvoir installer
un premiere pro ici donc c'est vraiment
assez limité mais si on veut faire un
petit peu de vidéo pour nous faire
partager très rapidement sur les réseaux
sociaux et bien on peut c'est pratique
si vous voulez venir jouer à quelques
jeux pas les plus hardcore mais jouer à
quelques jeux et vous avez pas mal de
titres également dans la galerie vivre
tout ce qui va être graphisme retouches
ont envie de venir s'amuser avec son
style et on peut bien le faire ce qui
est intéressant ici c'est l'usagé vous
alignez enfer avec votre clavier et avec
votre stylet alors le style est pareil
vous servir à venir naviguer à ouvrir
vos paramètres à faire ce que vous
voulez très facilement à revenir en
arrière si vous le souhaitez mais
également à prendre des notes coucou
vous voyez j'écris bien ce qui est
intéressant avec votre stylet si vous
faites un double tap là et vous changer
d'outil je suis passé de ma mine un peu
normal à ma gomme double top je continue
enfin bref voyez le truc est vraiment
très très très très pratique et très
intuitif si vous souhaitez venir castet
du contenu directement sur votre
moniteur ou votre télé bien pouvait le
faire grâce à venir hors castes et vous
pouvez également faire du multitâche
vous avez vos applications et si vous
avez plus qu à choisir vous cliquez
dessus ça vous les inserts comme ça si
vous souhaitez faire une conférence
rechercher votre recette pour le soir et
compagnie et bien pouvait venir le faire
et si ça c'est très pratique regardez je
vous parlais d'écosystèmes là
typiquement j'ai un ordinateur de huawei
j'ai mon ipad pro et bien je peux venir
les faire travailler ensemble sur mon pc
et ouvrez l'application web pc manager
je clique sur mes appareils et ensuite
peut venir connecter très facilement un
téléphone ou une tablette ici c'est une
tablette qui vous intéresse je peux me
connecter au plat je clique je trouve ma
tablette qui est juste là et là je suis
connecté là j'ai trois façons de venir
l'utiliser soit en mode miroir le mode
miroir c'est quoi c'est juste du
mirroring tout ce que je désire faire et
bien sûr mon ordinateur va se passer sur
ma tablette et c'est exactement la même
chose tout ce que je viens faire sans ma
tablette est bien va se passer sur mon
ordinateur c'est du mirroring pur et dur
soit en mode extension le mode extension
permet d'utiliser l'écran de sa tablette
comme une extension de son pc venir
glisser déposer emmener des éléments
d'un côté et de l'autre si je veux live
stream est directement sur mon pc de
huawei et ensuite mettre mon chat ou je
ne sais quoi ici sur la partie droite et
bien je peux le faire ça permet d'avoir
un deuxième écran donc si je vois un set
up un petit peu léger avec mon portable
et de côté ma tablette et bien je peux
le faire en déplacement et c'est très
très très facile soit en mode
collaboration la partie collaboration
est aussi extrêmement intéressant parce
que je viens glisser d'un côté et de
l'autre sur la partie de gauche j'ai mon
curseur ici l'ajout venir ouvrir à mes
paramètres sur ma tablette je reviens
ensuite ici pour venir bouger
directement mais et les mendois oui et
si j'aime bouger directement mon pc
manager sur mon pc l'intérêt c'est que
si je veux prendre un élément le glisser
le déposer d'un côté faire un copier un
collet et bien je le fais de façon
complètement transparente ça c'est
vraiment génial si donc ces trois façons
de venir collaborer grâce à pc manager
vous l'avez déjà présenté pc manager
avec des smartphones vous connectiez
très facilement votre smartphone
directement à votre pc et avoué faire la
même chose voire aller beaucoup plus
loin avec votre tablette de huawei et ça
c'est vraiment génial et c'est vraiment
toute l'idée ici qu'on me retrouver avec
la notion d'écosystème pc tablettes
moniteur vous avez derrière lehman view
mais également le smartphone le mec pad
est disponible en version si j'ai bien
drame 64 g de stockage à 399 euros que
vous avez une version 6 giga de ram 128
go de stockage à 499 euros 99 centimes
et le même palier disponible à
799 euros ils sont déjà dispo donc si
vous intéresse les liens sont en bas
dans la description maintenant la
question que je vous pose c'est est-ce
que vous êtes dans l'univers de huawei
est ce que vous avez un smartphone de
huawei est ce que vous ne pourra pas un
moniteur de voile ou est-ce que vous
avez pourquoi pas un ordinateur de
huawei et pour venir faire fonctionner
tout ce beau petit monde ensemble c'est
pour moi la grosse plus value si vous
voulez rentrer dans l'écosystème de
huawei et bien ces tablettes sont
intéressantes si maintenant vous avez
des produits qui ne sont pas
nécessairement dans l'écosystème de voix
vous pouvez venir les utiliser mais vous
pourrez être limité parce que vous
n'aurez pas les fonctions partage tels
que vous avez ici parce qu'il vous faut
un compte huawei et que globalement
l'idée ici est la notion que veut nous
mettre en avant moi oui sa notion
d'écosystème à vous de dire ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire casque
en a un des deux qui vous tente mais pas
de 11 mais pas de pros est ce que si ça
vous intéresse vous feriez réquisitions
avec un petit m pencil est ce que si ça
vous intéresse vous prendriez le smart
magnétique qui bordent moi ce que je
vous conseille ici réellement pour
maximiser l'expérience et le protéger
c'est prendre à minimale qui bordent qui
va avec tablet keyboard ça me semble
être réellement la base après le style
est bon de moi même je l'aurais pas
acheté mais je peux comprendre ça puisse
intéresser d'autres personnes j'en ai
pas usage si vous en avez lusage
pourquoi et une fois de plus si ces
produits vous intéresse vous avez le
lien en bas par la description voilà des
s'il a des gros bisous de l'amour a très
vite ciao